merci beaucoup Alain jolandet d'être
avec nous ce matin vous êtes sénateur
les républicains de la Haute-Saône de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées on va bien
sûr parler de la situation en Ukraine
dans quelques instants mais d'abord
l'actualité c'est la réforme des
retraites le gouvernement a donc
présenté son texte l'examen en
commission à l'Assemblée commence la
semaine prochaine et ça a été une
semaine compliqué pour le gouvernement
qui a du mal à convaincre les syndicats
continuent la mobilisation est-ce que
vous allez voter ce texte en l'état les
républicains nous sommes constants sur
le sujet nous avons toujours dit qu'il
faudrait réformer le système pour le
sauver pour sauver les retraites pour
sauver le système par répartition en
l'occurrence le texte en l'état n'est
pas juste et donc il faut le modifier
j'espère que le débat parlementaire va
le faire il y a un point qui pour moi
est absolument capital ceux qui ont
cotisé 43 ans doivent pouvoir partir
quand on a commencé à travailler à 20
ans plus 43 ans de cotisation égale 63
on veut pas demander aux gens qui ont
cotisé déjà 43 ans de faire encore un
avoir deux ans supplémentaires parce que
toutes ces personnes ne seront pas
considérées dans les carrières longues
les critères sont très complexes donc il
faut
faire préconisation
ations
ou les 64 ans donc où la mesure d'âge ou
la mesure de durée de cotisation ça doit
pas être les deux c'est pas juste et
donc je pense qu'il faut j'espère que le
débat parlementaire va permettre de
rectifier ce point qui pourront être
important qui n'est pas la ligne de tous
les républicains on est d'accord pas
forcément une BG cru comprendre que
c'était la ligne d'Éric sotti nous en
avions parlé sur ce plateau c'était une
proposition qui rassemblait entre ceux
qui voulaient pas du tout changer l'âge
légal puis ceux qui voulaient aller
beaucoup plus loin c'est-à-dire voir
jusqu'à 65 ans je pense que c'est une
position médiane qui est juste qui
permet normalement de de discuter avec
les syndicats l'autre point dans cette
réforme d'un point de forme j'allais
dire c'est que c'est invraisemblable de
pour le gouvernement d'avoir tous les
syndicats contre lui à chaque fois qu'on
a réformé le régime des retraites on a
toujours fait attention on a toujours eu
un syndicat réformateur avec nous qui
nous permettait de d'entrer dans ce
temps de vrai négociations
[Musique]
des retraites des fonctionnaires sont
payés par le budget de l'État donc
pourquoi est-ce que les autres systèmes
de retraite pourraient pas être
abondés un peu abonder un peu pour
permettre un régime par répartition qui
sont quand même un peu plus léger par
les salariés quand on va en arriver à un
retraité pour un actif comment on fera
on voit bien que c'est impossible donc
la réforme c'est encore une réforme à
court terme on pourrait peut-être
réfléchir un peu à l'avenir vous parliez
des syndicats qui sont opposés à
uneaniement au report de l'âge légal à
64 ans est-ce que les manifestations et
la mobilisation syndicale vous inquiète
est-ce que ça vous fait réfléchir sur la
manière dont vous allez examiner ce
texte aussi ça me fait surtout réfléchir
sur la manière dont on doit gouverner ce
pays et c'est jamais le moment réformer
c'est toujours difficile enfin là on est
dans un contexte et notamment en
province attire votre attention sur la
la forte mobilisation en province là où
on se sert beaucoup de son véhicule et
on paye encore l'essence à 2 euros ça
plus l'augmentation des prix dans les
caddie dans les dans les grandes donc
cette réforme retraite je crains qu'elle
cristallise l'ensemble de l'inquiétude
et des mécontentements des Français faut
arrêter de dire que les Français ont pas
compris et qu'il faut leur expliquer les
Français ils ont très bien compris ce
qui se passe et donc il faut trouver une
solution d'abord de dialogue de
négociation quand on veut pas faire tout
et bien on fait en partie les choses
l'essentiel c'est d'avancer c'est pas
pour vous par exemple le gouvernement
dit qu'il a dialogué avec les
parlementaires républicains Eric ce type
ou une retaille Olivier Marley sont été
reçus par Elisabeth borne et quand
compromis a été trouvé oui mais
d'ailleurs il y a eu des avancées
puisque notamment pour les retraites et
petites retraites le fait qu'elles
seront toutes à 1200 euros parce que les
républicains peuvent s'enorgueillir
d'avoir été pour quelque chose dans
cette dans cette avancée puisque le
président de la République était parti
sur 65
il faut faire quelque chose de plus
parce qu'il faut que cette réforme soit
juste il faut pas il faut pas expliquer
aux gens qui comprennent pas ils ont
bien compris et donc en ce moment
particulièrement en ce moment la réforme
doit être juste sur ce point là pour ma
part je pense qu'elle n'est pas juste
parler d'une agrégation de
mécontentement pour vous ça peut
déboucher sur quoi écoutez personne ne
peut prédire les choses je pense que ce
qu'il faut surtout souhaiter c'est que
notre pays s'appelle et on a besoin de
dirigeants je crois qu'ils comprennent
la situation qui comprennent nos
concitoyens qui soient en osmose avec
eux et qui dirigent qui dirige la France
différemment on a besoin de dialogue on
a besoin de participation
on a toujours dit qu'il fallait réformer
les retraites et moi je reste
sur ma ligne donc mais je pense qu'il
faut améliorer les choses il faut
dialoguer un peu il faut dialoguer
encore un peu plus qu'avant parce qu'on
voit bien qu'on est quand même dans une
situation française et internationale
qui inquiète tout le monde qui inquiète
y compris les anciens qui sont pourtant
des retraités qui n'attendent qui seront
plutôt avantagés par le système mais il
s'inquiète pour leurs enfants pour leurs
petits-enfants la France est en train a
pas de de traverser une période qui
nécessite un mode de gouvernement très
fraternel très consensuel qu'il n'y a
pas pour l'instant sur cette réforme des
retraites le député les républicains
puisque on connaît les amendements ils
ont été déposés du côté de l'Assemblée
le député les républicains Henri Dumont
a déposé un amendement pour supprimer le
régime de retraite spécial des sénateurs
comment vous avez réagi en voyant cette
proposition que je voudrais faire déjà
parce que faut faire attention à
l'enfumage le régime spécial des
sénateurs il est équilibré il n'est pas
subventionné par les contribuables il
n'est pas subventionné par l'État
contrairement à certains autres régimes
spéciaux qui sont déficitaires et qui
sont financés par le contribuable ou le
client des services publics etc au Sénat
le régime il est équilibré c'est-à-dire
ce sont les sénateurs actifs qui
financent la retraite des sénateurs qui
sont en retraite voilà donc c'est un
point comme je crois particulièrement
important par rapport aux autres régimes
solutions mais bon dans la période
actuelle il y a pas non plus de raison
de s'asseoir sur ce qui pourrait être
considéré comme un avantage moi je suis
ouvert à tout s'il faut réviser le le
régime spécial des sénateurs et bien
pourquoi pas allons-y parlons-en voilà
on peut pas on peut pas demander des
efforts à tout le monde sauf à nous donc
moi je suis très ouvert à tout ça
Pierre-Henri Dumont c'est un très proche
d'Aurélien Pradier Aurélien Pradier qui
était absent lors des vœux d'Éric cioti
absent de la photo de famille mardi au
sein de votre partie c'est un symbole de
l'échec du rassemblement d'érection
de lui c'est ça veut dire que au
contraire signement quelques lui ça veut
dire que tous les autres étaient là et
moi j'ai vu la photo j'ai vu la photo
autour d'Eric Ciotti le troisième
candidat Bruno retaillot était là lui il
n'était pas il est vice-président
délégué oui bah écoutez c'est un mauvais
signal bon toute façon quand quelqu'un a
absent c'est pas ça peut être un bon
signal enfin ce que je note quand même
c'est qu'Eric ciotique contrairement à
tout ce qui nous avait été pronostiqué a
été le Président nous avait dit s'il
était élu président les gens vont partir
personne ne part tout le monde est là au
contraire même ceux qui étaient ses
adversaires se battent pour avoir des
postes donc et puis c'est très bien
parce que ça veut dire qu'ils veulent
participer donc le rassemblement il est
largement réussi regardez la photo de
famille jusqu'aux anciens qui étaient là
jusqu'à François Baroin le président du
Sénat était là le président de notre
groupe le président de groupe à
l'Assemblée toute l'équipe est là
puisque on a même dit que le l'équipe de
direction était très nombreuse bon j'en
fais partie et voilà ce que je veux dire
au sujet d'Éric ciotis c'est qu'on va
petit à petit apprendre à le découvrir
un peu mieux moi je c'est pas un homme
que je connais depuis très très
longtemps mais c'est vraiment un
rassembleur et je veux dire c'est un
homme Constant qui est serein qui
j'avais dit je le redis je pense que
c'est un peu une force tranquille de la
droite et puis franchement parce qu'en
politique moi je suis très attaché aussi
au plan humain je pense qu'une belle
personne c'est une belle personnalité
voilà donc il le fait pas pour lui il
l'a déjà annoncé puisque il va il va
demander à notre mouvement de désigner
son la personne qui va soutenir pour les
les élections présidentielles prochaines
et je pense qu'il a raison parce que
c'est un grand or d'avoir désigné notre
candidate quelques mois avant les
présidentielles c'est pour être
président de la République de le faire
si tôt vous vous souhaitez
dès maintenant possible dès maintenant
parce que est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
candidats potentiels David Lisnard par
exemple peut-être qu'il faudra peut-être
qu'il faudra regarder tout ça mais Éric
Ciotti a été claire au moins il a dit si
c'est moi je proposerai que ce soit
Laurent Wauquiez j'ai soutenu Éric
Ciotti donc les choses sont claires
aussi voilà je pense que un président de
la République une présidente de la
République elle ne peut le devenir que
dans le cadre d'une relation avec les
Français il faut du temps pour faire une
relation avec les Français faut accepter
d'être cabossé il faut accepter de de
d'avoir des échecs aussi en six mois on
se révèle pas candidat ou candidates
pour les présidentielles
un mot sur un autre sujet on l'a vu dans
le journal le chiffre de l'immigration
ont été publiés hier jamais la France
n'a eu à traiter autant de demandeurs
c'est nettement supérieur à 2021 la loi
immigration doit être présentée en
conseil des ministres mercredi prochain
est-ce que vous allez faire des
propositions sur ce sujet dans le texte
d'abord j'attends le texte quand je
verrai le texte je vous dirai ce que
j'en pense moi en tout cas il y a pour
moi il y a un objectif la France doit
reprendre son destin en main en matière
d'immigration pour moi c'est l'objectif
principal et c'est ce que ce texte je
l'espère elle doit pouvoir nous
permettre de faire vous savez je suis
passé au gouvernement quelques années et
je m'occupais d'Afrique je suis allé
dans 40 fois ou 45 fois je crois en
Afrique
l'immigration c'est un sujet majeur pour
l'avenir et je trouve qu'on en parle pas
assez non pas d'immigration mais
d'Afrique on va en parler tout à l'heure
on va parler du Burkina Faso voilà donc
je pense que on a encore rien vu en ce
qui concerne l'immigration je pense que
le plus important est à venir c'est pour
ça législation française et pas
européenne une législation française qui
nous permet d'avoir notre destin
de lignes Gérald Darmanin et Olivier du
SOP pendant présenter les grandes villes
le gouvernement cherchent évidemment
rallier les républicains pour le faire
passer c'est un texte que vous pourriez
voter c'est un texte que je pourrais
voter bien évidemment bien évidemment
j'attends de voir ce qu'il a à
l'intérieur si c'est la question bien
sûr et si c'est une avancée pour une
reprise en main de notre destin
évidemment que que vous savez moi je
comme les républicains d'ailleurs nous
sommes dans l'opposition très claire
très clairement pardon mais en même
temps quand quelque chose nous est
présenté qui va dans le bon sens nous le
votons c'est la responsabilité
la responsabilité d'un parti de
gouvernement on va parler de l'Ukraine
11 mois après le début de la guerre en
Ukraine l'Allemagne les États-Unis et
d'autres pays occidentaux ont décidé de
livrer des armes des chars lourds à
l'Ukraine on fait le point sur ces
livraisons avec votre rêve et
[Musique]
bonjour Audrey bonjour bonjour et Audrey
on va donc faire le point avec vous sur
les livraisons de Charles aura l'Ukraine
oui Oriane car les choses se sont
accélérées cette semaine alors on va
faire un petit bilan on avait déjà 14
challengers britanniques promis début
janvier avant-hier les États-Unis ont
annoncé l'envoi de 31 chars un petit
bémol cependant le président a prévenu
l'envoi devrait prendre du temps et puis
il va falloir former les Ukrainiens à
l'utilisation de ces chars du côté de
l'Union européenne l'Allemagne a
autorisé la livraison de ces chars
léopard 2 à l'Ukraine il fallait cette
impératif il fallait son aval pour que
les autres pays qui en possèdent
puissent en livrer à l'armée de Kiev je
rappelle que c'est le modèle le plus
utilisé le plus répandu en Europe et que
les Ukrainiens savent l'utiliser donc ça
c'est quand même un point important dans
la foulée l'Allemagne a annoncé la
livraison de 14 chars d'ici mars tout
comme la Pologne je rajoute le Canada on
n'est pas dans l'Union européenne mais
ça nous fait un des léopard en plus 4 ça
nous fait donc 32 chars lourds en plus
des 45 britanniques et américains c'est
un début mais d'après les experts il en
faudrait au moins 300 à l'Ukraine pour
reprendre l'offensive et percer les
lignes mais il y a de la réserve la
Finlande les Pays-Bas la Norvège
l'Espagne et le Danemark ont promis dans
l'ivré on pourrait arriver autour d'une
centaine mais ces pays sont en fait en
train d'estimer ce qu'ils peuvent donner
parce qu'on est dans un contexte
instable et c'est compliqué de se
démunir dans cette période et la France
alors bien la France elle étudie la
question la réponse devrait arriver dans
les prochains jours elle possède des
chars des chars Leclerc qui ne sont pas
très répandues et qui sont assez
compliqués à utiliser à manier on
s'interroge sur l'intérêt de se démunir
pour livrer des engins dont l'Ukraine ne
pourraient pas forcément se servir la
première ministre était interrogée sur
le sujet mercredi aux questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement au Sénat
elle a rappelé que la France prenait
largement sa part et que l'Ukraine
l'aide à l'Ukraine ce n'était pas
forcément une question de Charles
écouter
aux côtés de nos partenaires la France
en prend une part importante nous en
sommes un des premiers contributeurs par
la livraison d'équipements de munitions
et la formation de centaines de soldats
Ukrainiens je pense aux canons César au
système de lance-roquettes unitaire au
système de défense aérienne
anti-aérienne crotale livrée en fin
d'année
nous entendons les demandes du président
et du gouvernement ukrainien rien n'est
exclu et nous sommes mobilisés pour les
soutenir dans la durée pour notre
adminitaire nous voulons respecter trois
principes le premier comme l'a indiqué
le président de la République c'est que
notre aide ne doit pas provoquer
d'escalade
on a l'impression qu'il y a des
tergiversations est-ce qu'on est à la
traîne sur l'aide qu'on apporte à
l'Ukraine
je pense que surtout dans les spectative
parce qu'on est entre deux possibilités
si vous voulez ou bien participer à
l'escalade ou bien participer à une
initiative de paix et moi je pense qu'on
devrait être beaucoup plus actif pour
participer à une initiative de paix et
là l'Ukraine c'est faire de l'escalade
et bien nous y voilà est-ce qu'on livre
des chars ou est-ce qu'on livre patcha à
titre personnel je pense qu'il faut pas
livrer de chat c'est pas parce que les
Américains le font c'est pas parce que
les Allemands le font que la France doit
le faire la France elle a toujours eu
dans le passé une position singulière
sur la question internationale la France
c'est un pays qui doit pouvoir parler à
tout le monde on a toujours eu cette se
soucie depuis le général de Gaulle de ne
pas être complètement aligné sur nos
amis et alliés américains et l'OTAN est
une est une une organisation qui est
absolument indispensable à la paix mais
dont nous ne sommes pas forcément
comment dire nous on doit pas non plus
être aligné sur sur le temps et je crois
que sur la question de l'Ukraine c'est
encore plus capital que sur les autres
conflits c'est à nos portes c'est en
Europe nos amis américains sont quand
même relativement loin de l'Ukraine et
donc la déstabilisation je parle
géographiquement la déstabilisation du
continent européen m'inquiète beaucoup
mais justement est-ce qu'il faut pas
aider l'Ukraine à se défendre face à
l'offensive russe l'Ukraine a dit nous
on a besoin d'aide militaire d'abord je
constate une chose c'est que tout ce qui
nous est dit n'est pas juste
rappelez-vous les commentaires dit à
quelques semaines on nous expliquait moi
je n'y ai jamais cru j'étais d'ailleurs
dit en commission des affaires
étrangères nous expliquer que le crâne
était en train de gagner la guerre et
que les Russes enregistraient défaites
après des fêtes qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire la demande pressante de char ça
veut dire si vous venez pas avec des
chats on a perdu c'est ça le message que
je que moi je que moi je comprends et
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure très
justement 73 chars c'est c'est un épi
phénomène si on veut arrêter la
progression russe vous l'avez dit
justement les experts aussi il faut
plusieurs centaines de chats ça veut
dire que les annonces qui sont faites
sont des annonces politiques et en
réalité les chiffres qui sont annoncés
sont pas les vrais chiffres il faudra
beaucoup plus de char que ça donc est-ce
que la France doit aller dans dans cette
démarche je suis très réticent pour ma
part je pense qu'il faut que nous
fassions très attention de préserver
notre dialogue avec la Russie notre
dialogue avec les autres
Vladimir Poutine aujourd'hui selon vous
on est dans une situation nous la France
avec notre diplomatie qui nous qui doit
nous permettre de discuter avec tout le
monde il faut pas qu'on fasse les choses
à l'envers écouter on a quitté
l'Afghanistan on voit le résultat on est
en train de se faire expulser d'Afrique
et est-ce peut pas participer activement
à des démarches de guerre à nos portes
moi je pense comme ça que il faudrait
que que la France préserve sa position
universaliste la France a un rôle à
jouer qui n'est pas celui de l'Allemagne
d'ailleurs nous n'avons pas le même
armement j'ai noté au passage que les
Ukrainiens ne demande pas de Charles
Leclerc j'ai entendu la déclaration du
gouvernement qui si on nous les envoie
on les accueillera avec plaisir ah bon
donc ça veut dire quand même que on
n'est pas dans la même position que les
Allemands que les Américains on a un
autre rôle à jouer ça veut pas dire que
comment dire que nous sommes des prorus
il faut faire aussi attention à une
chose je voudrais préciser il faut que
ceux il faut que tous ceux qui sont pas
alignés sur la position officielle
puisse s'exprimer aussi dans ce pays
sans qu'il soit tout de suite qualifié
de complotistes il faut quand même qu'on
ait un débat je suis d'ailleurs frappé
que est-ce que là vous demandez un débat
au Parlement sur l'envoi de ces chars
l'envoi d'armes et à l'Ukraine
la première ministre était déjà venue
s'exprimer devant le Parlement est-ce
que vous demandez un nouveau débat là
dans les jours qui arrivent il me semble
que pour prendre ce genre de décision un
débat au Parlement est absolument
indispensable dans un pays comme la
France on peut pas engager des forces si
les parlementaires j'allais même dire il
faut il faut aussi que les Français
alors pour le coup pour le coup il faut
aussi qu'on explique aux Français et ça
n'a jamais été fait pourquoi on
s'associe à cette affaire-là bien sûr
qui est un pays qui a envahi un autre
pays ça m'a pas du tout échappé mais
jusqu'à présent nous n'avons pas de
traiter avec les Ukrainiens nous n'avons
pas nous ne sommes pas alliés nous
n'avons nous ne sommes pas dans les
mêmes dans les mêmes scénarques dans les
mêmes organismes bien sûr bien sûr qu'il
faut respecter la liberté de l'Ukraine
et son territoire mais je pense que tout
ça est très complexe et la France a une
position qu'elle doit savoir conserver
en ne s'alignant sur personne et le
Parlement absolument doit être
effectivement associé
peut-être une question pour compléter le
président pour le direcalinski demande
désormais l'envoi de missiles de longues
portées des avions de combat ils
demandent ça à l'Occident quel est votre
réaction là-dessus vous voyez bien que
le terme employé par la première
ministre escalade est-ce que la France
participe à cette escalade voilà pour
l'instant on est dans un conflit entre
l'Ukraine et la Russie on aide l'Ukraine
parce que ce pays doit rester libre mais
il faut savoir doser notre effort savoir
doser
l'envoi de de d'Arsenal militaire
d'ailleurs vous savez la France
aujourd'hui et tout le monde le sait la
France n'est pas surréquipée elle a pas
beaucoup de réserves de munitions si
nous même devions faire face à un
problème je ne sais pas ce que ce que
serait la France toute seule donc il
faut réfléchir aussi à tout ça c'est un
grand enjeu pour l'avenir de notre pays
merci Audrey à tout à l'heure dans le
club pour nous parler d'un article oui
l'article 47 1 voilà c'est le 49 fois
vous expliquer le 47 ans ce sera tout à
l'heure donc on va continuer à parler
tes sujets et de l'Afrique justement
puisque le Burkina Faso a dénoncé
l'accord de 2018 sur le statut des
forces françaises présentes dans le pays
qu'on séquence la France va retirer ces
troupes d'ici un mois qu'est-ce que vous
avez ressenti en apprenant cette
décision beaucoup de tristesse beaucoup
de tristesse parce que Monsieur occupé
de de ces sujets là pendant quelques
années de très près je continue à m'y
intéresser beaucoup mais beaucoup de
tristesse parce que la France ne mérite
pas ça la France c'est beaucoup investi
depuis les indépendances aux côtés de
l'Afrique alors je sais qu'il y a un
mouvement de protestation notamment de
la jeunesse africaine qui en veut
beaucoup à la France paradoxalement
voilà mais je crois surtout aussi que
depuis une quinzaine d'années on
s'occupe plus de l'Afrique le pouvoir
politique en France ne s'occupe plus de
l'Afrique c'est c'est un temps c'est un
temps plein si vous voulez pour
quelqu'un au gouvernement de s'occuper
de nos relations avec l'Afrique il faut
voir chef d'État il faut voir les
ministres s'occuper des sujets il faut
anticiper comment vous l'expliquez je
pense que vous considérez que c'est une
erreur mais comment vous l'expliquez je
pense aussi alors il y a pas que ça si
vous voulez bon mais il y a pas que la
question de de qui s'occupe de l'Afrique
en France il y a aussi la question
de nos relations avec la Russie aussi il
faut tout ça allier évidemment hein la
France n'est pas en train de perdre pied
au sel et de laisser la main en russe
c'est ce qui est en train de se passer
si on ne si on ne réagit pas si on ne
reprend pas un peu la main il faut il
faut remettre en route manière très
active notre diplomatie vous savez il y
a beaucoup de travail qui se fait par
nos diplomates par le ministère des
Affaires étrangères qui n'avaient
d'ailleurs pas besoin de la réforme
qu'on est en train de lui imposer nos
diplomates en France sont
extraordinaires c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que la France à cette position tout à
fait unique dans le monde et c'est pour
ça qu'on a eu autant de possibilités de
de discussion avec les uns avec les
autres donc c'est vraiment un sujet
diplomatique majeur il faut reprendre
tout ça en main en espérant qu'il ne
soit pas trop tard et il y a la question
de la sécurité aussi nous l'oublions pas
pour l'Europe parce que le Sahel c'est
un endroit absolument stratégique pour
la question de la sécurité dans l'avenir
et pour ça que les troupes françaises et
en grande partie pour ça que les troupes
françaises étaient présentes sur place
est-ce que ça veut dire que tout ce
qu'on a fait depuis des années dans la
région du sel finalement on aura servi à
rien je pense que si on va jusqu'au bout
de la démarche je le crains si si on
voit se répéter au sein de l'Afrique ce
qui se passe actuellement en Burkina et
ce qui s'est passé au Mali je le crains
beaucoup je rappelle juste pour les non
initiés que la France a des accords de
défense avec plusieurs pays africains
qui prévoit que en cas de en cas de de
problème interne et elle a demandé des
États en question la France doit
intervenir donc c'était ça l'histoire
alors est-ce qu'on veut tirer un trait
tout ça
voilà que l'on réforme là aussi que l'on
réforme aussi nos relations avec
l'Afrique soit des relations gagnant
gagnant des relations de de partenariat
qu'il n'y a pas d'humiliation évidemment
tout ça il faut le faire mais la France
doit parler aux États africains s'il y a
pas une Afrique il y a beaucoup
d'Afrique différentes et la France doit
garder doit garder sa voix et ses
relations diplomatiques avec l'Afrique
parce que c'est de l'avenir de l'Europe
voyez bien que sur ce sujet là aussi la
France a une position particulière en
Europe dans sa relation avec l'Afrique
tout ça est très important merci
beaucoup Alain merci d'avoir été notre
invité pendant cette première demi-heure
dans 20 minutes dans le club des
territoires on vous emmènera sur les
traces de François 1er visite guidé du
château de Chambord puisque ça y est les
visiteurs reviennent à Chambord après
des années de crise sanitaire